everybody loves kungfu cooking a little
but the fastest cooking
lay take it away
that's races you are such a bit oh do we
have something special for you today my
friends put it hi we are gonna be making
David snows famous chili cheese fries
my penis flap and hit me in my belly
button yeah I got a long way now in
order to make chili before we go ahead
and start adding all this other [ __ ]
and etc etc etc you need to get your
fries now this I hand-cut myself liar I
bought it
set your [ __ ] to 400 degrees bow pundit
degrees we're getting the pan sizzling
hot my friends how do we start it off oh
yeah ground pork so delicious so
flavorful so fatty and of course ground
beef put the beef in oh [ __ ] there's
paper on the bottom ground pork there's
[ __ ] paper in this one - whoo Vanessa
who told you to put a [ __ ] tampon pad
in the bottom of this we want it to be
ripping hot and we're gonna cook this
until it's [ __ ] brown not soft ass
[ __ ] Brown if it's like that grey brown
you're not gonna want that you want it
to look like Luol Deng add the salt to
it add your pepper the rest of this
stuff we're gonna talk about later I'm
gonna move this to this side you see
that right in the pot see all those
juices coming out that's what we want we
want the moisture out we actually want
this to start crackling with fat we want
it to sound like a bunch of witches
laughing at you
remember how I said earlier we want it
to be Luol Deng sexy Brown we actually
don't we actually just want it to be
golden brown I just realize that little
thing is a little bit more toastier than
I wanted sexy black man a bit so if you
look at the bottom of the pen you'll see
these delicious like brown [ __ ] stuck
to the bottom that's good that's fun
that's flavor here this doesn't sound
like boiling anymore doesn't it sounds
like
sizzling fat and that's what you want
and as you can see there's not much like
wisps of moisture coming out anymore
because all of that like what it's gone
throw in your onions and of course the
diced red bell peppers
about two of them here's a little quick
trick for all you uh garlic lovers out
there Oh God when you have garlic you
don't need to sit there and pop all to
another [ __ ] take your garlic smash
it out a little bit take it on a flat
surface boom look at that smash garlic
throw it in there so after a few minutes
all that lovely moisture from those
vegetables are almost gone they're nice
and sweated out and sobbed they're
delicious and this is the important part
my friends it's going to be your spices
now to your chili you could add whatever
spice that you like but i'ma show you
what I'm going to add some people like
to make their own chili powder
I got type of that we're going to throw
in a copious amount of chili powder what
God and then I throw it a little bit of
mustard powder some cumin a little bit
of nutmeg and of course some Italian
seasoning which is a whole bunch of
dried herbs
oh yeah that's that chili smell I was
looking for and you're gonna let that
cook in that fat for a little bit cuz
we're gonna let those spices bloom in
that fat oh your smells so good
oh I want to dive my face into you boom
a nice dark caramel e beer a Guinness
Extra Stout just kidding use them
[ __ ] spoon if you're man
oh my god my knuckles oh not too much
we're just probably gonna use about 2/3
of a cup or so just to get it marry like
that and it's deglazing that bottom of
that pad with all that delicious pond
cook off that alcohol and you're getting
that delicious meat what do you call it
meat sewage next up however much whiskey
sure society you like I like about three
or four tablespoons boom put that in
there importante beef broth that's about
a cup of that some crush red tomatoes
now if you notice I'm not adding beans
because I don't [ __ ] like beans and
it turns out that chili originally
didn't even have beans in the first
place some [ __ ] [ __ ] put that [ __ ]
and everybody said it was supposed to be
like that jackass so I used roughly
about a small can of tomatoes and I'm
not gonna use any more than that see
what happens a lot to to a lot of people
when they make their chili they add way
too much tomatoes and it actually
becomes tomato sauce and you don't want
that you're looking to make delicious
meat garbage soup now up next we are
gonna work on the cheese sauce white
cheddar smoked gouda you could use
whatever achieve that you like let's
take half what is like 3-4 tablespoons
of unsalted butter in the pot get
yourself a whisk good with the cheese
sauce you're gonna need a whisk
typically you want half bad half flour
we're gonna go a little bit more
claiming that thickening power of this
wonderful thing let me get a measuring
cup actually scrape it off the top half
a cup of that [ __ ] throw it in there
cook this here for about two minutes do
not brown it blonde
we want this Beyonce nutmeg just a
little not too much nutmeg is very
powerful a little goes a long way and
it's very strong much like if Asian hens
penis you know that's what they say they
said an Asian guy's dick isn't as big as
other people's but is rock hard like a
marble stick next up hot room cold milk
no lumps put a little bit of it in at
first this is about a cup and a quarter
stick it in there stir it up turn up
that heat see how
whisking vigorously if you don't do this
during this process you're gonna get
loves you don't want that
sexy sexy throw it in and you're gonna
mix this vigorously now those french
fries which my friends we do not
deep-fry if we baked all ready to go
nice and crispy and crunchy toss them
around wait for it oh yeah take your
fries be generous with it you want your
friends to come to your Super Bowl party
you are gonna take your chili and you
are going to generously dump it on to
your fries like [ __ ] so generous after
that you are going to take your white
cheddar and gouda cheese sauce and you
are going to dump it all over as such to
top it off
don't forget green onions because we're
trying to be healthy with this dish boom
and there you have it my friends David
Souls ultimate cheese fries this right
here is Gouda licious once again if you
don't have friends make them this dish
that they still don't like you
they probably worship Satan whoa a
little bit of chili a little bit of
green onion little bit of cheese sauce
that's what's up this is [ __ ]
delicious man creamy cheese just ugh
she's delicious meat sauce with crispy
french fries
now I lightweight [ __ ] up on the
cheese sauce cuz I was worried that was
gonna be too hot it was actually too
cold and it made the cheese a little
lumpy but I'm talking right now you want
to play this when I shut this in your
mouth
[Music]
shucks technique also it gets the
attention of misbehaving kids legs
you guys wanna know and then looks like
Lin come here for a second ah just
kidding sit your ass down
nobody wanted to you we have all the
components of our dish ready [ __ ] this
dish I am so tired Chile has been going
uh something's [ __ ] burning I sort of
gone it's not my fries they're like some
crap on the book good Oh doesn't this
smell good everybody doesn't it if
you're vegan it probably doesn't smell
that good it probably smells like murder
and death but I've got beacon so it's
awesome I do respect a lot of vegans out
there and then how you guys want to
conserve the earth but there are people
like me who are gonna battle you to the
death